olá só coisa continuar a fazer história
aqui como vocês podem estar ver
estranhar
e foi do papel pois não tive nem fazer
uma pista com materiais muito básico se
vocês gostaram muito jovem mas foi o
corinthians que verás e percebe se o
pessoal gosta de coisa e fazer outra
coisa mas desta vez de fazer algo mais
fácil do que ninguém criou que uma hora
foi papel por exemplo é que o estado tem
força final é feito em papel
então vamos ao texto e tcheco nas
conclusões
[Música]
foi só um tipo de criança pequena coisa
do estado não ter centro da força uma
vez que é porque eu não sei o quanto é
contra ninguém e nem para encontrar
ninguém se eles sejam responsáveis e
para sempre usar íons e óculos de
proteção em torno do som podia os vossos
pronto é só isso
agora voltei a proposta basta só para
vocês fazerem arco e flecha aqui com
vocês podem ver foi papel e por isso
apesar da veemente papel duas folhas de
papel a4 emissora era rijo e não de
fazer um triângulo do brasil
esta parte aqui não vou usar o que vocês
quiserem podem fazer festa neste papel
com um domínio e podem usar com as
flechas do barco
agora temos aqui um quadrado linha a
linha
assim vamos conseguir lá daqui pra que a
parte inicial é que é mais complicado
você tem que fazer aqui tudo bem
compacta força ao mesmo tempo em que
mais de lado e vou pressionar mais desse
lado
ao mesmo tempo e já está agora solar
para fazer força e impressionar e que
não vão largar não vai estrelar tudo
resta agora é preciso fazer mais uma
coisa com mais um gol no começo e já tem
nenhum feito este aqui e vou continuar
quando vocês fizeram aqui é fita crepe
por compor vai fazer mais fazer o mesmo
para o outro na mesma proporção e já
está no grupo a ao lado da marca
já está feito agora no estado como a
pouco no lado em um mercado frágil
então apoiamos o fio supostamente
provavelmente vai dobrar e que podemos
contar isto sim vocês podem fazer
diferente e melhor
agora vamos aprender a aprender
vamos apertar las aqui a transição seja
mais suave aqui não conseguem ver em
cima da mesa assim vai ficar tudo no
lugar
agora fazer mesmo que testasse
já está agora a fazer estas partes
equipas aqui que já fizemos efeitos mais
bonita do brasil e agora vamos fazer
assim
está na hora de pensar e este esporte
que não fica muito bonito então votará
sim
com esta parte aqui não está muito
bonita muito apresentava já está melhor
silva está ligado à volta e ficou mais
bonita e ficou mais perto mas deste lado
fica melhor
o exército usou fita desta e prender o
fio e vou chegar aqui
agora lutar pelo estado
veja aqui a atenção
quem faz alguma força já está de volta
vou dar mais um nome que vai se
surpreender com a força do arco
se vocês quiserem perdoar os 9 mil por
uma pinga escolas tiveram um super cola
e vai ficar tudo me empenhar para cortar
os sexos
[Música]
você está agora vocês vão precisar dos a
flechas na frente vocês podem usar
licença agora em que um espeto leva uma
rolha aconteceu foi que cola já está a
planta fica cup
então acho que tanto trabalha vai ficar
sabendo destas em que você compra no
supermercado estiverem todas as
florestas é só cortar um carinho por um
tamanho certo já está e pronto acabou